i think you might have saved the biggest
one for last well danny that's right
believe it or not i've got more things
to show to you so how about we take a
leap of faith into the future together
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
well i think that's what you call big
news isn't it i mean there's a lot of
stuff in there that i think from your
point of view certainly the community
the fans have been asking for for a long
time so mac tell us more well this is
code name red our next premium flagship
title and the future of our open world
rpg games on assassin's creed
it is being developed by ubisoft quebec
the studio behind assassin's creed
odyssey under the creative direction of
jonathan zuma
it will let players explore one of their
most awaited settings ever on the
franchise feudal japan and they'll live
a very powerful shinobi fantasy i mean
people have been waiting for this for a
long time haven't they yes they have
they certainly haven't now you brought
it to them it's amazing which is good
and you're slightly cruel in that you're
teasing me with it i very much want that